Youtube Rewind did an oopsie!
PewDiePie, I mean PewDiePie 👉 did an oopsie!
Soulja Boy, did an oopsie.
And the Forbes, did an oopsie.
I'm Oopsie Doopsie. Oopsie doopsie doopsie.
Woopsie time :D
👏👏👏 [Pew News intro] Oopsie!
[Pew News intro]
Welcome to Pew News, the most diverse news source of all time.
We have literally everyone working here.
People are campaigning to get PewDiePie more subscribers
because...
A. He needs to destroy 🅱️-Series
B. Because he's the most epic Youtuber
Or, C. "Because straight men have too much time on their hands"
[moment of silence]
[applause]
BECAUSE sTrAiGhT mEn HaVe ToO mUcH tImE oN tHeIr HaNdS
I'm not saying people shouldn't be straight,
I just don't need their culture shoved in my face all the time.
Heh. Straight people be like:
"Subscribe to PewDiePie everybody."
I don't even know if this is a legit website.
I-- hndjhjdhahaha[dies inside]
You know, if people campaigning for PewDiePie to get more subscribers have too much time on their hands,
what the FRICK do people that complain about it have, huh?
Destroyed with Facts and Logic, 🅱️icc
"Literally what do sTrAiGhT nErDs spend their money on, question mark."
Oh this site is legit.
[dies inside again]
Oh, it's legit, alright.
[clap clap] To be fair.
The whole "subscribe to PewDiePie" thing
has just become a meme.
It's getting out of control, I'll admit to that at least.
I had one of the stra-- I mean, PewDiePie had one of the strangest days, I can only imagine.
When, uh, not only Jordan Peterson,
"Hey Jordan what are you doing right now?"
"I'm subscribing to PewDiePie."
but also Logan Paul
urges people to subscribe to PewDiePie.
I mean, what the frick is going on here, guys?
"Logang, I have put a trackable link in the description of this video that,
WHEN CLICKED,
will automatically subscribe you to PewDiePie's channel."
So Logan Paul said that day, he would donate to charity of his choice for every person that clicks his link to--
that redirects to subscribe to PewDiePie hehe...
𝗜'𝗺 𝗱𝗲𝘀𝗽𝗲𝗿𝗮𝘁𝗲. 𝕀'𝕞 𝔻𝔼𝕊ℙ𝔼ℝ𝔸𝕋𝔼 𝔾𝕆𝔻𝔻𝔸𝕄ℕ𝕀𝕋.
I mean, Logan wanted me to wear his merch.
As a, as an exchange for this.
"You must wear this piece of Maverick merch in one of your upcoming videos
CURRENTLY being delivered to you via courier."
Okay, first of all, I didn't give Logan my address cuz I--
I didn't know what the hell he wanted.
I gave him the address of a Swedish crafting shop.
BUT! I'll keep-- I'll keep the promise
that I never made, I guess.
But then again, you look at the graph, and you see the sub gap and--
I mean, it's not even nearly as impactful as the Markiplier one.
See, here is when Markiplier did the shout-out.
And here is when
Logan did his.
But I think there's one thing we can learn from all of this, which is of course:
SUBSCRIBE TO PEWDIEPIE
It's not that hard.
It's one click away.
What the FRICK are you doing?
To be honest, I am a bit overwhelmed by the whole thing.
The sub gap is still... reducing.
My twitter is just over-blown with:
"Subscribe to PewDiePie"
All these companies getting into it.
PornHub: "Subscribe to PewDiePie"
"Playing 🅱️icc Lasagna in a mall until someone asks me to stop in order to save PewDiePie."
And there's-- there's more events going on from fans and other YouTubers than I could possibly keep up with.
Grade Calculator: "Don't want to study? Subscribe to PewDiePie!"
Like, what?
People hacking GTA to say "Subscribe to PewDiePie"
But my-- my favorite, which of course, is:
"PewDiePie supporters call on Prime Minister Theresa May to help him defeat T-Series"
Yes, that's right everybody. That's an actual headline.
As much as I'm absolutely humbled and so happy about all the support,
I'm-- I do feel really weird about it, and
I wanted to do a shout-out to a bunch of smaller creators as well,
or that maybe don't have alot-- as much subscribers just cuz
There's a lot of great channels on YouTube that actually deserve subscribers.
I know "Subscribe to PewDiePie" is a meme and all and I appreciate it,
but I made a list and it's in the description and I'll go through it at the end of this video,
of channels that I watch that I think deserve more subscribers
or that I just enjoy watching
NEXT👏 NEWS👏
YOUTUBE REWIND [weak clapping]
You've probably seen this train-wreck of a video already.
Did anyone actually like the video?
Poor YouTube.
You know what?No.
NO. STOP.
The reason I'm bringing up YouTube Rewind again is because
It's made history.
That's right
As the "Fastest Most Disliked Video of ALL. TIME."
On Wikipedia: "YouTube Rewind
became the fastest video to climb this list, gaining over 4 million dislikes in less than 48 doh-- hours."
And it's currently the 2nd most disliked video on YouTube.
YouTube beat my own video of "Can this video get 1 million dislikes?"
I mean, PewDiePie's video.
It needs 9.7(*million dislikes) to become the most disliked video on YouTube,
which is "Baby"by Justin Bieber.
That's crazy, I didn't think-- it's not THAT bad.
But as always, passing the question unto you guys.
What do you think about it?
I mean, I don't even have to critique the video, it just speaks from itself.
You just watch it and it's just a cringe-fest
"A celebrity in rewind"
"A Twitch streamer in rewind"
"A YouTuber who hasn't posted a video in 9 months"
And I don't wanna be all salty in the fact that I wasn't in Rewind,
I kinda get it.
I guess that thing is I thought last year was equally bad, but it seems like this year,
I guess is the year where people really opened their eyes to...
how uh... how much YouTube has really changed in their approach to its creators.
👏 NEXT👏 NEWS👏
SOULJA BOY.
Exciting news from Soulja Boy.
Finally!
SouljaGame Console AND Handheld.
That's right, they're here!
GameRevolution made an article about it.
Soulja boy tweeting: "Wow, my console is selling fast." $$$
"Dreams do come true. Thank you fans, this is only the start."
Well he wasn't kidding, it really was only the start.
Now, the handheld version has over 3000 games in it, and
if you question its legality or why this exists then
WHAT THE FRICK GU--
You're just a hater!
This thing has Gameboy Advance games and all kinds of stuff.
Dude! It's got an RCA output.
Haven't seen those in years.
Thank you Soulja Boy for bringing that back.
HDMI? I don't think so!
Now if you can not, just like myself, have enough of Soulja... Soulja Boy's product,
he, of course, has the SOULJA WATCH!
If you're a true Soulja, part of the Soulja Army.
But you wouldn't just have the handheld. You wouldn't just have the console. You wouldn't just have the Soulja Watch.
You would also have the SOULJA PHONE.
That's right.
Oh you wouldn't-- Not even that. You're not a true Soulja fan unless you have the SOULJA GIFTCARD.
[wheeze]
Soulja Boy was very pleased with the reaction about his game console,
saying that: "To the first person that purchased my game console,
you just brought tears to my eyes. Tears of joy!
Thank you so much for your support, I promise to continue my tech company and evolve it in the gaming world.
I'm just a kid with a dream ¯\_(ツ)_/¯
After the release of Soulja Boy...
Game Console, as you probably would have guessed already
Nintendo stock completely plummeted.
X-Box, Microsoft stock
practically non-existent.
Playstation stock...
committed seppuku(press F to pay respects)
If it wasn't obvious, these are practically just Chinese knock-off products that you can buy already.
For also a much lower price on different websites.
The console, it looks identical and it sells for $30, but if you want the Soulja Boy version, then
It's a hundred ninety-nine.
Soulja Boy is just an artist that I truly respect and truly admire for his integrity,
his innovation, but most importantly, his rap game, of course.
You've probably heard of this website called "Cameo" where you can pay B or C-list celebrities to get a shout-out.
Now, I did it and 9 out of 10 said no.
I was gonna do a video where I make fun of all these desperate YouTubers for accepting this brand deal but
Surprise, surprise! No one wanted to do it!
Except ONE MAN!
ONE MAN was greedy enough for the challenge.
Let's watch.
"It's ya boi Soulja Boy shoutin' out to ma' man Felix man.
Ya already know what it is
How's it goin' bros my name is PewDiePie. Yo!"
Yo!
[sex sound]
Thank you Soulja Boy!
VERY! COOL!
NEXT👏 NEWS👏
🎉
"When fans go too far: PewDiePie, 'stan stunts', and Youtube's next big problem"
Now, I mentioned this before uh, I think in last LWIAY,
because this article by the Telegraph attacking me and my fans for being "problematic",
It came out the exact same day that we raised $250,000 for CRY, the Indian charity for-- to prevent child labor.
I usually ignore this kind of stuff, but I just thought it was crazy how they posted this at the same time.
But, this article, you have to PAY to read it.
And I-- I never bothered to pay for it, but some of you guys sent me a screenshot of it and it's--
It's hilarious.
Because it talked about the "Subscribe to PewDiePie" hack
and how, uh...
the hacker, as they mentioned it, HackerGiraffe,
is rumored to be only 9 years old.
[r u srs]
👏👏👏JOURNALISM EVERYBODY👏👏👏
👏👏👏GOODJOB👏👏👏GOODJOB  EVERYBODY👏👏👏
👏👏👏👏👏👏👏
👏👏👏YOU DID IT👏👏👏
It seems so many people fall for the "9-year old" meme I love it, it's so good.
Anyway that's all I have to say.
NEXT👏 MEME👏(?)
Forbes made a-- their yearly top 10 list of the most paid YouTubers or gamers or whatever they do.
They always reached out and-- to ask if the numbers are correct. I don't think
"CUZ IT'S NONE OF YOUR BUSINESS FORBES."
But let's have a look at it.
Logan Paul is #10
PewDiePie was #9
Jacksepticeye beat me to it.
😠😠😠
Vanoss Gaming 😠😠
Markip--ᵍᵒᵈᵈᵃᵐᵐᶦᵗ
I think DanTDM was the highest paid last year if I remember correctly.
Now, a lot of people seem to take these as facts. It's just pure speculation. Like, Forbes has no idea.
So there's really no reason to even take this seriously.
But they did rank Ryan ToysReview #1, a literal 9--s--9 year old. SEVEN year old.
When he gets 9, OH BOY.
Things are gonna be different around here.
Not everyone was too pleased about this list,
and the main reason I'm bringing this up is because
my newly favorite YouTuber,  Lily Singh, has some interesting things to say about it.
"2 years ago, it was almost even between male & female, last year it was just me, and this year, there are no females at all."
So, she was on the list last year, but now she-- there's no female on the list this-- this year.
"Something I predicted in my Instagram caption last year.
I'm concerned the digital space is going to repeat the mistakes of ancient industries. Hope I'm wrong."
[ʰᴼᵖᴱ ᶦ'ᴹ ʷᴿᵒᴺᵍ]
You know, maybe this is a crazy idea, but maybe you should uh...
Maybe you should plan a campaign or something like that to increase your revenue?
Something about uh.. mental health?
And then just come back and sell a bunch of merch afterwards.
That would be a great idea, maybe that will help you earn more revenue.
"Hey guys I work too much, I need a break.
BUY MY HUSTLE MERCH!"
Imagine being actually mad about the fact that a 7 year old made an--
is the most paid YouTuber.
I think what's interesting about this whole thing is it's saying that
"men are being paid more than women in the YouTube space"
which is obviously just ridiculous, you don't get paid more or less based on your gender.
AdSense pays the same way. If people wanna subscribe to you, they generally do it because they enjoy your videos,
not because of your gender, that's just ridiculous.
But if you start complaining about this, you literally just sound like a crybaby and an idiot,
which you are, Lily Singh.
Just in case you weren't sure.
💥💥💥
That was it for Pew News, hope you guys enjoyed this video.
We reached 75 million subscribers.
It's so ridiculous.
I have a video waiting to go up, that we worked day and night to make happen,
at the time when 🅱-Series gonna pass,
that I can't upload now, because you guys KEEP SUBSCRIBING!
Stop subscribing.
And in fact, subscribe instead to all these channels that I'm about to list now.
Video's over, but if you want to keep watching, you can subscribe to:
James Lee, he does incredibly cool videos. He's an animator. Check it out, definitely deserves more subscribers.
We have NakeyJakey, who, he has a considerable amount of following, but he's just a great channel, still underrated.
He does video game essays and talk about stuff. That's right, that's the best explanation I can do on the fly.
Check him out, subscribe.
William Osman, great channel, he's an inventor, and he does all these crazy builds.
He had a laser-cut Vin Diesel ham and cheese sandwich.
Alright, here's an actually smaller channel called alfsvoid.
She does political and social videos. Talking about these interesting topics she does in a very engaging and interesting way.
I really enjoy watching her, great channel.
Then we have apandah, who made a "Top 10 Reasons Why You Should Sub to PewDiePie"
He expected a sub payment for this, but instead you get a shout-out, so stop asking me for money, alright?
Next up we have Ape Trvp Visuals 猿, i don't know I just like this, I just like it, okay?
He does really sick animation edits, with cool SoundCloud rap music in the background.
Bacon_, which I've shouted-out before. He does the funniest Oblivion meme. Definitely check him out, check out Bacon_.
He also, last time I shouted him out, he told me about the LaFave Bros who is doing an Oblivion playthrough right now.
Small channel, they're really funny guys. He's the one that did the original Oblivion parody videos that I reference so many times in my videos, they're so funny.
And speaking of Oblivion, check out also Wilburgur.
We also have Bepis, he's a great meme channel, definitely subscribe to Bepis. He's helped me out with a couple of Meme Reviews as well so, I really appreciate it.
We also have diesel patches, a great channel that calls out a bunch of bull**** on YouTube if you like that kinda stuff, check him out.
We have DPO23, it's just a hilarious channel.
I watched him in yesterday's video, You Laugh You Lose, so ******* funny. Check him out.
Dylan Locke, he did a remix for 🅱icc Lasagna, it's absolutely amazing. Imma gonna re-upload it in my channel in a couple of days,
but he's super underrated, guys. Super talented. I don't know what to call him. Mixer? Editor? I don't know.
We also have E;R who does great video essays about uh... he did one on Death Note, which I really really enjoyed.
Next up, we have Eight Thoughts, he's another channel that calls people out generally on a bunch of bull****. Really entertaining, I enjoy watching his videos.
I gotta give a shout-out to my man EvinEdits. He did this amazing edit of the PewDiePie anime opening.
Just a talented memes-- A good old memester everybody. Actually I don't know if-- ʸᵉᵃʰ ᴵ ˢʰᵒᵘˡᵈ ˢʰᵒᵘᵗ ʰᶦᵐ ᵒᵘᵗ ᶜᵘᶻ ʰᵉ'ˢ ᵈᵒⁿᵉ ˢᵒ ᵐᵃⁿʸ ᵍʳᵉᵃᵗ ᵒⁿᵉˢ ᶠᵒʳ ᵐᵉ.
I also gotta give a shout-out Ian Kung. He's kind of like the live sketch version of grande and dolan. I hope he doesn't mind that description.
I gotta give a shout to Joe Jenkins. He did this hilarious video where he played 🅱icc Lasagna on actual lasagna.
Also of course, kmlkmljkl, another amazing meme account. He uploads very frequently. He or she i don't know.
nihonium, as well, of course. Another great meme account, you should follow.
Memology 101, great channel as well. Found through 'Better Help' stuff. Uploads very frequently, always on top of topics, really enjoy this channel.
I gotta give a shout to Saiman Says, he did this video called "Thank You PewDiePie!",
and he basically explained in Hindi my kind of humor, and why you shouldn't be offended by it.
It thought it was really cool, he'd draw examples of how the 🅱icc Lasagna memes and
how "You India, You Lose" is a reference to "You Laugh, You Lose" and "You Slav, You Lose", which I made fun of before and
Just a really funny guy like, I think it's really cool what he's doing.
We have Sarah Z, who does reviews and video essays, very entertaining, check her out. Great description.
We also have surreal entertainment, already gave him a shout, such a funny channel. SWEDISH BOY, shout-out to my Swedish boys.
"Oh no. All my children died."
I recently discovered this channel, but it's goddamn amazing. The Pruld.
It's just-- it's Dark Souls enemies. I-- But thy're so goddamn good.
We also have wavywebsurf, sub-tier PewDiePie, check him out, very good.
My favorite channel though, Супер Сус, I mean, this channel is an absolute treat.
[vodka language idk]
He's the Lily Singh of Russia. Does daily vlogs.
We also have Nyarons (にゃーろんず/Nyarons - bassy & chika)
I don't know how to say it. If you wanna listen to some music that will instantly put you in a better mood, check out Nyarons.
Why don't we just end it there? Thank you for 75 million subscribers.
I'm gonna link all these channels in the description. Check them out, why not? Look, find some new channels.
And uh, that's it for me for now. Goodbye everybody.
(Hi, I don't want to bother you guys but, in return for me putting subs on this video,  please stream Nu'est W - Help Me. THANK YOU BROS!)